[Rires]
[Musique]
vous faire vivre ce lancement que vous
allez voir sur cet écran vous l'avez vu
tout à l'heure c'est celui de Starship
la fusée la plus puissante du monde a
priori qui va être lancée et alors on
était déjà là il me semble il y a
quelques jours c'est ça lundi Cyril on
est reparti cette fois-ci a priori
jusque là tout va bien tout va bien le
compte à rebours se déroule normalement
et donc on est à 12 minutes d'un
décollage qui sera historique parce que
c'est la fusée la plus puissante au
monde c'est
la fusée géante d'Elon musk c'est de la
fusée avec laquelle ils vont envoyer des
hommes sur Mars c'est voilà on est on
est à bout de on a passé une superlatif
pour le décrire elle est
gigantesque elle est à 33 moteurs au
premier étage c'est du jamais vu enfin
voilà donc et elle est elle a été conçue
pour être entièrement réutilisable à la
fois le premier étage donc la partie
basse
et le vaisseau noir qu'on voit avec la
c'est des tuiles de protection thermique
pour résister à la rentrée dans
l'atmosphère et et voilà il y avait que
les navettes spatiales qui a été
récupérables et pour les navettes on
récupéré la navette elle-même mais pas
les gros réservoirs pas les boosters
parce qu'il fallait des mois et des mois
de travail pour remettre un navet en vol
ici SpaceX a appris des leçons et des
échecs de la navette et l'idée c'est de
revoler son sang délai en remplissant
juste le réservoir en revenant sur le
papier c'est en fait c'est de faire un
peu des lancements à cadence
industrielle exactement en fait
ce que racontait la vision la vision de
notre must tel qu'il a décrivait il y a
déjà c'est la première fois il en parle
c'est en 2017 et il explique en fait que
c'est absurde de jeter à chaque fois une
fusée
toutes les fusées actuelles avancent de
SpaceX ont été jetables donc c'était du
consommable une Ariane 5 elle décolle
elle finit en Océan et tout est perdu il
faut reconstruire tout début de voilà
donc et la logique ce que imaginé Elon
Musk c'est de dire maintenant il faut
que le secteur spatial devienne comme
l'aéronautique comme l'aviation civile
on jette pas un A380 après un dégringer
on garde finalement tout le long c'est
ce qui va se passer alors c'est la
logique mais pas aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
tout est perdu mais on veut voir si dans
le futur ça marchera et donc là c'est la
première fois que les on voit très bien
la société vue d'ensemble on est à Boca
Chica au Texas c'est tout près de la
frontière avec le Mexique en bord du
golfe de Mexique donc de la mer et et
on voit les deux parties on voit la
partie noire au sommet donc ça c'est le
vaisseau Starship c'est c'est le
vaisseau qui va servir à la NASA
important c'est le plus important c'est
à la fois pour l'envoyer des satellites
mais aussi pour remporter des
astronautes et c'est ce vaisseau là qui
se posera sur la lune avec les
astronautes de la NASA dans le programme
Artémis donc le retour sur la lune c'est
la pièce maîtresse c'est ce vaisseau
les astronautes décolleront sur une
autre fusée dans une capsule mais autour
de la Lune il rentre il rentre dans le
vaisseau qui rasseposer à surface de la
Lune c'est-à-dire qu'en fait c'est ça va
être complètement pilotable du ras de
vaisseau complètement pilotable ça a
l'air assez incroyable dit comme ça mais
on aura un vaisseau pilotable autour de
la Lune qui prendra des gens et qui va
se reposer tranquille ment en fait
l'idée du vaisseau c'est le il sera en
orbite permanente autour de la Lune il
serait il sera rechargé en carburant par
d'autres Starship iront le voir
échange de carburant en orbite et ça
sera oui le moyen de faire la navette
entre une orbite autour de la Lune et la
surface de la Lune mon n'y est pas
encore c'est c'est le NASA parle d'un
atterrissage sur la Lune en 2025 mais
objectivement personne n'y croit si ça
se fait avant 2030 on sera déjà très
heureux
très content que ça se passe comme ça si
j'ai bien compris alors je salue Michel
et Alcor qui nous ont rock qui nous ont
rejoint dans le chat alcoqi j'espère
qu'elle se lancera aujourd'hui oui parce
que moi je me souviens dans la discuté
on vous a fait ce live lundi et Alex
Cyril on disait bon c'est pas forcé on
n'est pas 100% sûr que ça va se lancer
aujourd'hui il y avait même plus de
chance qu'elle ne partent pas
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a plus de
chances qu'elle partent oui clairement
en fait le lancement de lundi enfin la
tentative de lancement lundi pour être
plus juste
il y avait jamais eu de ce qu'on appelle
de répétition générale qui fait une
simulation totale du compte à rebours
jusqu'à ou à la seconde qui précède à
l'image des moteurs quand on a avant de
lancer en fusée une fusée généralement
on fait cette opération remplit les
réservoirs on fait toute la décompte du
compte à rebours jusqu'au bout pour
vérifier que la procédure est comprise
que les il y a pas de problème technique
donc ce qui s'est passé lundi avec un
problème sur une vanne de pressurisation
des réservoirs du premier étage
finalement c'est un peu un aléa qui
aurait été détecté s'ils avaient fait
cette répétition donc cette tentative
elle a servi un peu de répétition
générale
sans le dire en fait à savoir alors on
va bien sûr vous avez ces images on va
bien sûr surveiller parce que la
dernière fois on avait eu tout ça et
c'était Elon Musk qui qui annonce en
fait
qui dit alors là alors parce qu'on a
dans l'oreille en même temps qui nous
dit que ça va décoller dans 8 minutes on
a 8 minutes de l'allumage des 33 moteurs
au premier étage on a une vision là
incroyable avec cette tour de lancement
voilà 120 mètres de haut pour le
l'ensemble le premier étage qui est plus
clair qui est en inox en acier brillant
et deuxième étage qui lui en partie
recouverte de tuiles de protection
il fait la météo on a de la chance à la
météo est extraordinaire le ciel est
absolument dégagé donc on devrait suivre
l'ascension de Starship pendant un bout
de temps si il fallait les conditions
sont aussi ils sont aussi claires là on
peut voir justement ce pâtir en droit
c'est incroyable et on le rappelle aussi
SpaceX ils sont quand même très forts
aussi pour une chose c'est on dire
scénarisé au maximum leur lancement de
fusée alors oui oui
l'échec est pris en compte dans la comne
de SpaceX c'est-à-dire que en fait là
dans le le décompte le compte à rebours
que nous donne SpaceX à 0,00 c'est
l'allumage des moteurs le décollage de
la fusée et ce qu'ils ont écrit c'est
xitement garantied donc c'est
l'excitement l'excitation est garantie
et en fait c'est ça soit un échec ou un
succès ça sera spectaculaire spécif le
sait ils ont fait les vidéos avec des
compilations de leur plus leurs échecs
les plus on l'a vu d'ailleurs au début
il se vendent de rater beaucoup pour
pouvoir réussir en fait et en fait c'est
c'est oui c'est une fierté elle est pas
et c'est pas une fierté déplacée en fait
c'est vraiment dans la logique de
développement de SpaceX on revient un
peu au début de la de l'aéronautique ou
l'astronautique où on construit des on
construisait beaucoup de prototypes on
les fais voler ça marchait pas toujours
on avait à l'époque on n'avait pas de
simulation informatique mais on
apprenait énormément de choses et c'est
la logique de SpaceX vole après vol ils
apprennent ils repoussent les limites
ils comprennent du coup ils peuvent
pousser curseur il réduisent les marges
de sécurité pour augmenter les
performances et donc c'est un
apprentissage continu alors là on a une
vue incroyable c'est les 33 moteurs sous
le premier étage
chaque moteur c'est 200 tonnes de
poussée c'est plus de 100 tonnes de
poussée c'est plus puissant que le
moteur Vulcain unique moteur Vulcain
voilà donc en fait ça va on est sur des
par rapport à ce qu'on a vu parce que
vendredi dernier on a fait le lancement
d'Ariane 5 l'avant dernier lancement
d'Ariane 5 d'ailleurs et ça ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui rien de ça alors voilà
rien de 5 elle arrive elle arrive en
hauteur elle arrive à la moitié là de
Starship elle est bien plus fine plus
petite pour le tas de jouer mais quand
même non c'est pas un jouet parce que ça
peut rien dire qu'elle peut déjà envoyer
20 tonnes en orbite autour de la Terre
donc c'est déjà considérable c'est c'est
dans le top de ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui
mais avec Starship on passe dans une
gamme au dessus la gare la gamme des
lanceurs super géants on n'a pas on n'a
pas en fait
d'équivalent qui existe aujourd'hui
et en mode réutilisable l'objectif c'est
d'utiliser de pouvoir lancer dans
l'espace entre 100 et 150 tonnes oui
effectivement c'est
on gagne en plus et si on est en
configuration la récupération de
carburant la récupération des étages ça
consomme un peu carburant donc on perd
de la performance si on lance Starship
sans récupérer les étages on peut
potentiellement envoyer 250 tonnes en
orbite autour de la Terre c'est à dire
en un seul lancement on peut lancer
l'équivalent de la Station spatiale
internationale qui a nécessité une
centaine de lancements étalé sur 10 ans
c'est un changement d'échelle
tête de yop qui nous dit c'est quoi la
destination de cette fusée là c'est la
destination c'est la mer les deux
c'est que les voyelles la fusée va être
perdue les deux étages vont être perdus
alors pas de récupération aujourd'hui
mais la destination c'est c'est une
orbite c'est une trajectoire ce qu'on
appelle subordinale c'est-à-dire qu'on
va pas aller jusqu'à faire une autour de
la Terre on va faire une casière orbite
c'est-à-dire que le vaisseau Starship il
va faire trois quarts de la tour de la
terre et retomber dans le Pacifique au
large de la Californie
et donc elle va aller le Starship il va
aller dans l'espace il va aller au Lac
tranquillement d'altitude il va être
dans le vide spatial et il va rentrer
dans l'atmosphère ça va être une phase
importante pour voir comment il survit
en fait qu'on ne verra pas aujourd'hui
parce qu'elle se elle aura lieu au bout
d'une heure et demie de démission oui
mais ça fait partie de la mission et
l'objectif donc c'est un vol suborbital
on est c'est presque presque en orbite
mais mais l'idée en fait c'est de ne pas
laisser
avec ce genre de trajectoire on est sûr
que tout retombe sur terre
en cas de problème sur un vol d'essai
c'est pas c'est le Starship est laissé
en orbite
ça fait ça fait un débrie spatial un
contrôlé potentiellement ça peut être
dangereux de 500 tonnes et là ce serait
vraiment une très très mauvaise idée
donc la trajectoire qui retombe dans
l'océan c'est la certitude que quoi
qu'il arrive succès ou échec il y aura
pas de problème pas de pollution en
orbite alors vous voyez ce compte à
rebours 3 minutes 3 minutes avant le
départ et pour l'instant pour l'instant
parce que la dernière fois on est allé
au bout du compte à rebours 40 secondes
mais ils avaient annoncé je crois 6 ou 7
minutes avant que le lancement n'aurait
finalement pas lieu la a priori le
lancement va aller au bout en tout cas
jusque là et puis on n'est pas non plus
à l'abri que ça se passe très mal et que
tout explose avec explicite le risque le
gros risque aujourd'hui pour spécif
parce que l'échec donc il est il est
pris en compte dans l'essai il est
possible il est il est envisagé
la catastrophe c'est l'explosion sur le
pas de tir ou un très faible attitude ou
celui pas de tir qui détrurait les
réservoirs de recharge chargement des
carburants et donc ça c'est une
catastrophe ça coûterait ça ferait
prendre des mois et les mois de retard
au minimum
mais sinon le voilà le
chèque fait partie du programme il est
il envisagé il est envisagé je salue
Messi Denis B qui sont là et qui vont on
va vivre ensemble ce lancement puisque
là a priori tout va bien il est à deux
minutes avant le lancement on disait un
lancement qui est complètement c'est
après on entend d'ailleurs tous les tous
les employés SpaceX parce que ça aussi
c'est c'est c'est très mise en scène on
a des caméras que vous voyez voilà avec
tous les employés de Space X dans
l'imagine qui sont là pour faire le plus
de bruit possible pour le lancement ils
sont en fait ils sont ils sont en entre
là ils sont en Californie à automne
c'est là où est l'usine qui fabrique les
Falcon 9 d'accord
et il y a un esprit de corps un esprit
de
groupe de fierté travaille chez SpaceX
je crois est assez incroyable enfin il y
a une motivation qui est décuplée par le
l'idée qui sont en train de repousser
les limites et de faire avancer le
spatial comme aucune entreprise la fait
avant alors une minute 17 avant le
lancement alors peut-être expliquer ce
qu'on voit sur ces images parce que on
voit beaucoup de fumées
alors là c'est les excès de remplissage
des réservoirs il y a deux carburants
donc il y a de l'oxygène liquide et du
méthane refroidi donc méthane c'est le
gaz naturel ils sont les températures
hyper froides pour gagner en densité et
pour prendre le moins de place possible
de pouvoir augmenter la quantité qu'on
augmente qu'on en voit
on voit sur cette image les la tour de
lancement avec deux bras métalliques
noirs juste au-dessus juste à côté du
vaisseau Starship
c'est les baguettes qui vont venir se
refermer et à terme récupérer le premier
étage qu'on y reviendra se poser il va
venir se poser au même endroit que là où
il est parti c'est l'objectif et donc il
sera récupéré par ses baguettes puis
après reposer sur le pas de tir
délicatement
en théorie ça sera pas testé on va voir
ça effectivement alors le lancement est
prévu pour dans 30 minutes 35 secondes
vous voyez le compteur on va vous
laisser vivre ce lancement avec les
images et on revient monter le son parce
que ça va faire beaucoup de bruit
alors vous venez peut-être de l'entendre
sur les images mais en tout cas de sur
les enfin ce qu'il a dit en anglais mais
ça ne partira pas tout de suite non il y
a eu il y a eu un moment d'arrêt le
compte à rebours a été arrêté et donc
voilà on est en face de je pense qu'ils
sont en train d'évaluer la situation il
doit y avoir un voyant qui est au rouge
sur les oui parce que alors ça les
conditions de lancement
alors on me rappelle un nous nous on
écoute aussi en même temps ce qui se
passe eux ils sont en train de voir de
l'autre côté ils ont dit qu'ils allaient
revenir assez vite on se rappelle sur le
lancement d'Ariane 5 il y avait un
panneau avec 20 LED on avait
l'impression je crois que c'était ça
voilà 20 panneaux lumineux il faut que
tout soit vert si on a un qui est rouge
on arrête tout de suite une série de
paramètres à la fois les installations
au sol qui donc charge le carburant qui
vérifie les systèmes de bord il faut que
la fusée soit ouverte il faut que tous
les systèmes embarqués
soit
opérationnel il faut que les moteurs
répondent bien il faut que enfin il faut
que la météo soit bonne là c'est le ciel
est dégagé il y a pas de souci risque
d'orage tout ça où les vents aux
altitudes ça peut empêcher un lancement
là il faut qu'elle soit réunies pour un
lancement
on n'a pas pour le moment on n'a pas de
détails on leur a sûrement enfin voilà
enfin voilà on va la voir dans
l'oreillette on nous ne sommes pas les
ingénieurs de de SpaceX à avoir toutes
les informations en temps réel on
regarde bien évidemment ce qui se passe
sur les différents Twitter puisque Elon
Musk et SpaceX communiquent en temps
réel via Twitter donc forcément on voit
ça tête de yop qui demande il y a
combien de personnes à l'intérieur et
personne pour l'instant il y a personne
parce que quand même on vous rappelle
que on va quand même essayer de pas
récupérer les choses donc on espère
qu'il y a personne dans ce vaisseau dans
plus sérieusement par contre comme on
l'a dit au début de ce live après ça va
amener du monde
oui le le vol d'essai donc c'est un vol
automatique avec personne à bord
mais à l'avenir le but de Starship à la
fois de lancer les satellites et
d'envoyer les astronautes dans l'espace
de les faire se poser d'abord sur la
lune puis après l'objectif de musk c'est
vraiment mars il a il a il veut
coloniser mars donc il veut transformer
l'humanité en une
civilisation
interplanétaire alors on a une annonce
on va avoir une annonce dans pas
longtemps on va écouter ce qui nous
disent dans l'oreillette effectivement
j'en profite pour parler un peu des des
commentaires
on nous dit
c'est en différé non non nous sommes
nous sommes en direct nous sommes en
direct avec un léger un léger différé
peut-être dû à la connexion de là-bas
pour récupérer les images mais nous
sommes bien sûr en direct
donc en fait il y a un léger problème de
pressurisation sur le les réservoirs du
carburant du premier étage apparemment
la donc on a arrêté du compte à rebours
à 40 secondes avant le départ et ils
essaient de voir quel est le problème
sur le pressurisation des modes des
réservoirs en fait comme on a un
carburant qui est liquide et qui est
très léger
qui se dégaze il faut qu'il soit
pressurisé
on va reprendre le compte à rebours à
moins 40 secondes ah alors le savoir
partir ça va partir on vient de
découvrir on vient de l'entendre ça va
partir on nous dit dans les dans les
commentaires fail ça ne marche pas on
rappelle que si ça ne part pas le vrai
échec aujourd'hui pour SpaceX c'est pas
que ça ne part pas c'est que ça explose
tout Oui pour le pour l'instant c'est
pour ça qu'ils font très très attention
un retard en avant le laisser c'est
jamais un échec enfin c'est il y a pas
de petits contretemps bénéfique parce
que on imagine que détruire tout il vaut
mieux attendre un petit peu en fait le
l'objet l'objectif de la mission
aujourd'hui c'est d'apprendre pour les
ingénieurs de SpaceX c'est d'apprendre
et donc même avec ce petit aléa sur le
compte à rebours au départ je suis sûr
qu'ils vont ils vont découvrir des
choses ils vont comprendre et améliorer
pour les procédures pour les points
suivantes ici donc reporter un lancement
et résoudre des problèmes ça fait partie
de l'apprentissage il semblerait que le
que ce que le compte à rebours va
reprendre
ça y est il est reparti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous venez de vivre ce lancement va vous
expliquer ce qui se passe lors de
recensement déjà on a vu ça
impressionnant une fusée qui fait autant
de de poussière de films et en fait on a
on a eu un décollage malgré on le voit
en bas gauche de l'écran malgré
plusieurs moteurs qui fonctionnent pas
on a l'impression qu'il a qu'il a mis un
temps fou à monter à se sortir du pâtir
c'était vraiment extraordinaire on voit
on est une vue sur les moteurs on voit
il y a des trous dans le dans le dans le
dans ce réseau lumineux c'est les
moteurs qui sont arrêtés qui ne
fonctionnent pas il a au moins 1 5 2 3 4
5 il y en aurait cinq actuellement de
moteurs qui ne fonctionnerait pas et
même sans ces cinq moteurs cette fusée
peut décoller et ben elle fait plus que
décoller là on est on est déjà à 1000
km/h et à 12 km d'altitude donc ça va
très très vite ça continue d'accélérer
voilà
c'est juste incroyable c'est juste
extraordinaire on l'a entendu même si
les micros sont forcément un peu loin et
le bruit que ça fait c'est
incroyable oui c'est en fait c'est voilà
au niveau bruit on a on n'a pas
d'équivalent enfin pour l'instant de
fusée ça dépasse Saturne 5 la fusée
lunaire des missions apollée ça dépasse
la navette spatiale
on va bien on se rapproche du de
l'extinction du premier étage il va y
avoir la séparation la séparation ça y
est
[Applaudissements]
donc là et là on a une vue dans les
moteurs de deuxième étage donc le moteur
Raptor deuxième étage du Starship le
vaisseau Starship d'accord donc en fait
là vous avez vu il y avait moteur on a
ça y est c'est la vue avec la séparation
on voit le premier étage qui est déjà en
train de redescendre et donc normalement
cet âge-là bientôt devrait tomber à un
endroit bien précis devrait se reposer
de façon normale on va dire alors il va
il va faire une simulation
d'atterrissage ce premier étage
on espère qu'ils ont mis des caméras
partout pour nous mais oui oui la caméra
embarquée c'était le premier étage en
fait
j'ai l'impression que les moteurs du
Starship sont pas allumés
ouh là là c'est il y a un problème on a
un gros problème
l'attitude du Starship du nom du premier
étage
alors voilà on voit le premier étage qui
descend tout bilan je ne pense pas que
ça soit normal il y en a priori c'était
pas normal mais on analysera bien sûr ça
effectivement normalement c'est censé
être contrôlé ils ont ils sont censés
peut-être que c'est justement c'est
c'est moteur qui n'étaient pas assez il
fallait tous les moteurs pour qu'il pour
qu'ils reviennent normalement et là
c'est parce qu'il va se passer
d'ailleurs Cyril en train de prendre ses
fiches puisque on a le compte à rebours
en fait de ce qui va se passer donc là
clairement là il y a perte de contrôle
sur l'attitude du booster donc du
premier étage qui devait tenter de
redescendre à la verticale il sait pas
encore désintégré et mais clairement il
va pas se poser de façon très très il va
pas se poser du tout et j'ai
l'impression que les moteurs du Starship
ne sont pas allumés non plus donc pas
décoller alors on pour l'instant on n'a
pas de nouvelles de ce qui s'est passé
explosion du premier étage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que ils auront ils seront pas
aller au bout de leur test on peut dire
alors non ils ont pas ils ont pas réussi
tout ce qui était possible de réussir
dans ce volcès mais
honnêtement enfin c'est
déjà un succès la fusée a décollé et la
dépassé la tour de lancement et il est
allé elle est allée jusqu'à la
séparation avec le deuxième étage donc
ces deux phases critiques sur lequel
il y a énormément d'informations et on
voit Elon Musk que le premier plan avec
le sourire
donc un sourire franchement de sourcils
je sais pas mais on a du mal on a du mal
à voir effectivement ce qu'il dit on a
recommencé à quelqu'un qui nous dit que
la le premier étage va tomber sur sa
maison on rassure quand même que tout ça
est quand même assez calculé que on ne
lance pas diffuser sur les non non on
est la fusée elle était au-dessus du
Golfe du Mexique au-dessus de la mer
donc il y a pas de risque pour les
populations et je pense qu'on a vu une
explosion contrôlée du lanceur d'accord
qu'il ne tombe pas droit
il y a une des assemblée des assemblages
contre rapides
par une explosion mais mais c'est pas
c'est pas un échec total
ils auront appris des choses lors de ce
lancement par contre s'il y a quelque
chose qu'on va surveiller forcément dans
les dans les plus dans les dans les dans
les heures à venir tout de même c'est
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé
au deuxième étage oui alors en fait il y
a plein plein de questions qui se posent
déjà pourquoi il y a cinq moteurs donc
qui ont pas fonctionné correctement il y
en a un qui était qui j'ai vu qui a été
éteint en cours du vol d'accord
il y en avait trop au début puis il y en
a un qui effectivement et donc ça c'est
résoudre parce que même s'il y a de la
marge sur la performance notamment pour
se voile d'essai où il y avait pas une
charge maximale à emportée par la fusée
l'autre question c'est cette séparation
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pourquoi le
Starship les moteurs sont pas allumés
pourquoi le premier étage est perdu
contrôle il s'est est-ce que c'est un
changement de d'attitude ça fait quand
même c'est quand même 70 mètres de haut
le premier étage c'est c'est plus gros
que rien de 5
c'est c'est
un immeuble de 25 étages qui contrôler
et à faire redescendre droit non
seulement ça il faut qu'il fasse
demi-tour parce qu'il est en face
d'ascension il faut qu'il fasse
demi-tour pour revenir vers le pas de
tir donc c'est les efforts et des
contraintes sur un objet hyper complexe
hyper lourd oui on rappelle aussi que
c'est pas c'est pas piloté c'est
le pilotage de bord qui s'occupe de tout
ça d'accord
c'est c'est
piloter en direct ou est-ce que c'est on
a rentré des calculs et il est sur le
pilotage automatique tout le long
pilotage automatique tout le monde ouais
ça il y a pas quelqu'un dans une
cabine sur terre qui dit pour aller
maintenant on tourne et on fait
demi-tour et on se pose personne n'est
capable de réagir assez vite pour
piloter une fusée comme ça d'accord il y
a que l'ordinateur qui est capable bon
il y a peut-être un problème justement
c'est peut-être un problème logiciel sur
le après
en fait tire réutilise ce qui sait ce
qui sait faire avec Falcon 9 Falcon 9 il
y a déjà les dizaines et des dizaines de
premiers étages qui ont été récupérés
qui se reviennent sur poser maintenant
de manière presque routinière sur des
barges ou sur des zones près des pas de
tir donc c'est quelque chose que
spécifique maîtrise mais là on a une
structure qui est bien plus complexe
bien plus lourde bien plus grosses donc
tout est plus compliqué en fait et c'est
ça c'est là l'objectif c'est d'apprendre
un maximum sur sur ce qui peut se passer
ce qui doit être maîtrisé sur ce qui
peut se passer ce qui ce qui doit
arriver on va voir passer d'ailleurs ces
images qui étaient qui étaient tout à
l'heure alors là on est plus sur du
direct on vous remontre ce qui s'est
passé puisque le webcam c'est comme la
dernière fois c'est qu'en fait tant que
tout va bien on continue en direct tout
le long des images de synthèse alors ça
c'était à 17 minutes avant le compte à
rebours j'ai je suis revenu en arrière
sur la vidéo de nous ne sommes plus
actuellement en direct mais c'est pour
vous montrer un peu ce qui se passe à ce
moment là on arrête le webcam parce que
voilà on a plus grand chose à raconter
on va dire à ce moment là c'est terminé
on aura des nouvelles on imagine dans
les heures et les minutes à venir sur ce
qui s'est passé le but c'est de
comprendre et de de voir ce qui s'est
passé et des
jusqu'où jusqu'au SpaceX à repousser les
limites parce que quand même le but
c'est ça c'est ce qu'on va sur ces
images on le rappelle c'est d'aller sur
Mars c'est c'est la conquête du système
c'est le l'objectif de Elon Musk il y
croit c'est la conquête du système
solaire transformer l'humanité en une
espèce interplanétaire
colonisée mars donc ça veut dire être
capable d'envoyer des des centaines de
tonnes en orbite et et poser des êtres
humains envoyer des êtres humains dans
l'espace donc voilà c'est extrêmement
ambitieux c'est un budget qui n'est pas
connu on sait pas combien ça coûte
mais on sait que
un contrat il y a un contrat d'un
milliard et demi de la NASA pour
développer le vaisseau qui va poser les
astronautes Artémis sur la lune et on se
doute aussi que tous les bénéfices de
SpaceX vont dans le développement de
cette fusée géante qui est l'objectif
ultime de musk
voilà si il était juste là pour faire de
l'argent
ça peut être pas aussi pressé pour de
faire cette fusée mais on sait que le
personnage est complexe et qui veut
aussi barquer marquer l'histoire et
c'est c'est aussi ça son but il faut
renvoyer sur sur cet article Starship
Berlin mars et au-delà un très beau
format fait qu'il vous explique un peu
comment tout se passe comment tout va se
passer sur le futur et voyez d'ailleurs
je voulais vous montrer d'ailleurs ça
parce que on vous donne des comparaisons
depuis tout à l'heure mais donc
là c'est le Starship tout à droite et
c'est avec ça qu'on partait sur la vie à
l'époque donc on est on est sur encore
plus puissant encore plus gros et c'est
destiné totalement utilisable donc c'est
voilà c'est pour ça que c'est une
révolution c'est pour ça qu'il y a
autant d'attentes autour de il y avait
autour d'attente de ce premier vol
forcément et on n'est pas déçu c'était
magnifique c'est magnifique est-ce que
est-ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un
lancement alors je sais pas si vous
pouvez nous dire mais est-ce qu'il y
aura un lancement bientôt de ce un
nouveau lancement ils vont communiquer
bien sûr j'en imagine sur le calendrier
oui enfin j'espère qu'on aura des
justement des dates après ça va dépendre
en fait des modifications qui vont qui
vont devoir faire sur les prochains
modèles de vol si c'est si c'est quelque
chose de lourd et un défaut de
conception majeur ça peut prendre des
mois et des mois si c'est de
l'ajustement du reprogrammation du
logiciel
c'est peut-être pas très compliqué donc
mais ils ont les capacités de construire
on pense qu'il est construisent un
moteur fusé par un moteur Raptor par
jour le moteur de du premier étage donc
des capacités de production ils sont
très rapides
on verra peut-être qu'on aura peut-être
rendez-vous dans quelques semaines pour
voir un deuxième décollage
ce sera bien évidemment avec plaisir on
a juste une pas mal de questions dans le
dans les commentaires des gens qui sont
peut-être arrivés un peu en retard
est-ce qu'on peut leur rappeler ce qui
s'est passé lors de son sponsor Cyril
donc premier vol d'essai du Starship en
dans son ensemble avec le vaisseau et
son son booster son premier étage et une
décollage hyper impressionnant avec un
nuage de fumée de fou un décollage très
lent l'impression qu'il est arrivé du
mal à ça assez extraire du sol il y a
quelques moteurs qui ont pas fonctionné
sur les 33 du premier étage
la mission est allée jusqu'à la
séparation entre les deux étages
le et là et là ça s'est moins bien placé
parce que les moteurs de deuxième étage
sont pas allumés alors on ne sait pas on
ne sait pas actuellement ce qui s'est
passé du deuxième étage puisqu'on a on a
eu des images avec les moteurs pas
allumé donc on imagine que ça s'est très
mal passé mais on n'a pas d'infos donc
pas vous le dire et le premier étage on
l'a vu on l'a vu désintégrer
alors que l'objectif c'était de le faire
revenir vers le pas de tir et c'est
simuler un atterrissage contrôlé au
dessus de la mer ou tu les vagues et
donc ils ont pas du tout aller jusqu'à
jusque là et ça sera pour les prochains
vols ça pour les prochains vols et on
les suivra en direct merci beaucoup
Cyril d'avoir été avec nous vous pouvez
retrouver bien évidemment cet article
que je vous montre tous les autres
articles d'ailleurs sur le le sur le
Figaro bien évidemment dans la rubrique
science vous pouvez retrouver tout ça et
vous pouvez être sûr que le prochain
lancement on sera là bien évidemment
pour vous faire vivre cela la suite du
programme sur le Figaro live c'est bien
sûr la question du jour qui arrive dans
un petit quart d'heure 16 heures je
serai là pour vous le faire vivre vous
pouvez rester avec nous sur le site du
Figaro et je vous dis à bientôt